اهلا بك يعني هذه العمليه الاعلان عنها في
هذه المرحله ما دلالته ما
اهميته نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
نعم حقيقه هذه العمليه يعني نستطيع ان
نقول بانها جرت سابقا في اكثر من مره يعني
وبالتالي هناك امكانيه وقدره للجيش الص
الصهيوني على تنفيذ مثل هذه العمليات في
هذه المعركه وبالتالي تستخدم هذه العمليات
عندما تكون هناك قوات موجوده في مناطق
اماميه ولكن يصعب الوصول اليها من قبل
القطعات المتواجده في المنطقه فيمكن ان
تقوم القوات بايصال العتاد والوقود
والغذاء عن طريق الطائرات سواء كانت
الطائرات المروحيه او الطائرات ثابته
الجناح وبالتالي يمكن القاء مثل
هذه مثل هذه الامدادات لهذه القوات اضاف
الى ذلك عندما تكون خطط خطوط الامداد
طويله ايضا يمكن ان نستخدم مثل هذا مثل
هذه مثل هذ هذه الطائرات لايصال المساعدات
للقوات المتقدمه ولكن بشكل عام بانه قد
عندما تكون هناك قوات محاصره في منطقه
معينه ايضا يمكن ان نلجا الى مثل هذا
الاسلوب في ايصال المساعدات او ايصال
المواد التي تطلبها القتال في الفتره
وبتال نعم اذا سمحت لي الاعلان عنه في وقت
تزداد الضغوط الداخليه والجدل في داخل
صفوف المؤسسه العسكريه عن الطريقه التي يع
بها الجنود في الميدان هل هذا ربما
لاحتواء اي نوع من الخلاف او الغضب الذي
يتزايد
مؤخرا نعم قد تكون مثل هذه الدلالات ولكن
بشكل عام يعني عمليه ايصال مثل هذه مثل
هذه الامدادات من الوقود والعتاد والغذاء
هي مساله طبيعيه سواء كانت عن طريق البر
او عن طريق الجو ولكن عندما تكون هناك
صعوبات في ايصال مثل هذه الامدادات يمكن
ان يكون القائها من الجو عن طريق الطائرات
المسيره او الطائرات ثابته الجناح ولكن
بشكل عام نقول بانه القوات المتواجده الان
في في خان يونس او في بقيه المناطق الاخرى
قياسا بالقطاعات التي كانت متواجده سابقا
هي قطاعات قليله ولا يمكن لها ان تقدم شيء
على ارض الواقع لانه لا يمكن عندما تكون
قطاعات كبيره جدا تصل الى اربع فرق او خمس
فرق ولا تستطيع ان تحقق انجاز عملي على
الارض لا ممكن ان نتصور بان هناك فرق اقل
منها كفاءه وقدره وامكانيه على ان تحقق
شيء خلال الفتره القادمه ولكن مع هذا نقول
بان مثل هذه الامكانيات المتاحه للجيش
الصهيوني يمكن له ان يستخدمها في ايصال
المساعدات الى قواته المتقدمه في هذه
المنطقه طيب ماذا عن سير المعارك بشكل عام
والاعلان عن الخسائر من جانب اسرائيل
اصابه او مقتل جندي احتياط ضابطي احتياط
واصابه 35 عسكريا خلال 24
ساعه نعم دعيني اقول بدايه عندما يتكلمون
هم عن فرقه 36 يقولون بانه سحب هذه الفرقه
قد يؤثر على ساحه القتال طيب هذه الفرقه
كانت موجوده والصواريخ كانت تنطلق من من
غزه سواء كانت من الشمال او من الوسط او
الى الجنوب ولم تتاثر الفصائل المقاومه
بوجود هذه الفرقه الان مع انسحاب هذه
الفرقه لازالت الخسائر تزداد بشكل كبير
والدليل على هذا بان الموقف الان في
المنطقه الشماليه يحتدم بشكل بشكل او باخر
لان هناك عمليات تنفذ الان من قبل فصائل
المقاومه لانه اذا ما تكلمنا عن لواء
الشمال بيت لاهيه بيت حانون وهذه جباليه
وهذه المناطق توجد فيها سبع
كتائب للقسام اما اذا تكلمنا عن منطقه غزه
فيها ايضا سبع كتائب اخرى اذا نتكلم عن 14
احنا 14 كتيبه لفصائل المقاومه في هذه
المنطقه ونقول بان هذه هذه المنطقه لازالت
تمسك من قبل فصائل المقاومه مستفيده من
شبكه الانفاق التي تصل الى مناطق متعدده
في في في في المدينه ولذلك نقول بان
استمرار العمليات العسكريه سوف يستمر الان
حتى حتى وجود الفرق الاخرى سواء في القاطع
الاوسط او القاطع الجنوبي لن يغير من
المعادله شيء يعني اذا ما جينا الان على
ترتيبات او على تطورات المعركه نجد بانه
لا تبدل في الموقف هذا هذه القطعات تراوح
في مكانها منذ فتره ولا تستطيع ان تحقق
انجاز عملي على الارض لذلك نرى بان
الخسائر تزداد يوما بعد يوم يعني عندما
نتكلم الان مثلا عن الاسرى الاسرى 136 شخص
طيب الان الخسائر التي يدفعها الجيش
الصهيوني بتواجده في داخل مدينه غزه هي
اكثر بكثير من الاعداد الموجوده لدى حماس
من الاسرى وهذا يتناقض يعني لا نعرف كيف
كيف يمكن للقياده العسكريه ان تقبل بهذه
الخ سائر بهذه الطريقه التي تجري للجيش
الصهيوني ومع ذلك يستمرون في التواجد سواء
في القاطع الاوسط او في القاطع الجنوبي او
في القاطع الشمالي كيف تفسر ذلك انت يعني
كرجل عسكري ما الذي تعتقد انه يبرر هذا
التصرف نعم يعني يعني دعيني افصل في هذه
المساله عندما نتكلم عن فرقه 98 فرقه 98
الان تقاتل في في الجنوب في خان يونس هذه
الفرقه فيها ثلاثه اربعه الويه احد
الالويه تم تسريحه قبل اكثر من 20 يوم 551
بقيت فيها ثلاثه الويه لواء ال 35 مظليين
لواء ال 55 مظليين ولواء 89 لواء كمندوز
هذا اللواء فيه اربعه كتائب تم سحب احدى
الكتائب اللي هي كتيبه دوف دفان وارسالها
الى الضفه الغربيه لانها هي من نظام معركه
الضفه الغربيه علما بان الضفه الغربيه
الان الامور تتصاعد فيها بشكل كبير جدا
وهناك تحسب لدى رئاسه الاركان بان هذا
الجبهه يمكن ان تنفتح بشكل او او باخر
فلذلك يجب اخذ الحيطه والحذر ف تم سحب هذه
الكتيبه وارسالها الى الضفه الغربيه بقي
تقريبا لواء ناقص عندما نتكلم في القاطع
الاوسط الفرقه 99 توجد فيها اربعه الويه
لواء ال 11 هذا احد الالويه لواء 179 لواء
مدرع واللواء الاخر هو اللواء
646 يعني عندما نتكلم عن هذه القطعات
المتواجده القطعات تقريبا نستطيع ان نقول
بشكل او بعام فرقتين ناقص ولكن عندما ناتي
الى تطورات المنطقه في المناطق المبنيه
نجد بانها قد تحتاج الى قطعات اكبر من هذا
بكثير ومع هذا لم يتم انجاز اي شيء طيب
بقاء هذه القوات مع مع وجود فصائل
المقاومه في القاطع الجنوبي وفي القاطع
الاوسط بكتائب متكامله تقريبا لم يتم
دخولها في المعركه في الفتره السابقه
بمعنى انه المعارك يمكن ان تكون ضاريه
بشكل كبير على هذه القطعات ونرى اليوم
يعني عندما نتكلم عن الامداد اللوجستي
الان عندما يتم القاه من الطائرات اذا
هناك معضله لدى القوات التي تقاتل في هذه
المنطقه ومع ذلك يصر الكيان الصهيوني على
الاستمرار في هذه العمليه هناك خلل كبير
جدا في الخطط عندما يتم سحب القوه ال 36
الفرقه 36 وبعد ذلك يتم الكلام بانه
اخطاوا في سحب هذه القوه اذا ما هي الخطط
التي يعمل عليها هناك اشكاليه حقيقيه في
اداره المعركه هناك اشكاليه حقيقيه في وضع
الخطط وهناك نستطيع ان نقول اشكال في
القطعات التي تقاتل حتى في الداخل بالنسبه
للجنود معنويات الجنود هناك اشكال في
عمليه الدعم اللوجستي الان لديهم وبدات
الان تظهر المشاكل بشكل اكبر مما كانت
عليه في السابق لذلك نرى بان فاتوره
الخسائر كلما ازداد توغل هذه القوات في
الداخل كلما ازدادت خسائر بسبب العمليات
التي تنفذها فصائل المقاومه التي استطاعت
ان تحافظ على بنى تحتيه خلال هذه الفتره
ساعدتها في اسمرار في هذه المعركه لحد هذه
وصلت الفكره العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من
اسطنبول شكرا لك